Oh shit, sorry.
That's all the different stuff.
Whoa, sorry.
Ha ha ha!
Sorry, how many loops have we been?
I lost track.
How many loops has it been, guys?
I literally just got back.
I had to, like, move my laundry stuff and put in new laundry things.
Oh my god, I'm a little bit of a mess right now.
Um, alright!
So, as we all know, we're not starting right away because we have a story time!
Woo!
Story time!
Let me grab chat.
I rushed home.
Um, okay, so, like, I have several stories.
Several, several stories.
But I'll start off with, like, I'll start off with a story that, like, some of you guys are gonna be like, Oh, Doki again.
Again, about this Marvel Rivals.
Doki, please get... Okay, look.
Um, alright, so!
Update regarding Marvel Rivals on Twitch.
Um, I will...
The only times after yesterday...
Okay, so for those who, like, didn't watch yesterday's Twitch stream, yesterday's Twitch stream where I streamed Marvel Rivals on Twitch, apparently after the third or fourth game, you know how I was winning a lot?
And then after, like, third or fourth game, like, um, things got a little bad.
As in, we basically...
I got confirmation from Gomez that I was basically, like, sniped every game.
LOL lol lol So, um...
So, yeah, so, from now on, if I'm streaming at, like, late-night queues, I will be force stacking at late-night queues or, yeah, force stacking at late-night queues because I was like, I can't deal with that.
But, um, if I'm streaming it on Twitch at normal hours, like, you know, peak hours, I will be, um, I will be like, I can solo, I can solo duo.
It's just that late night is a little, is a lot rougher now.
And then, my manager, I was telling my manager about this, and they were like, congratulations, now you know how every popular streamer felt, feels when they're streaming on Twitch.
Congratulations Doki, you're popular now!
I was like, but I, I, but I don't want to be streamster!
They were like, that's what every streamer has to go through.
You made it, Doki!
And I'm like, but I didn't, but on YouTube it doesn't happen to me!
They're like, the manager's just like, you do know, every streamer at your level and more, has, goes through this every fucking day.
You do know that.
I was like, but they don't know I exist on YouTube, so I never had to deal with it.
I, I never had to deal with it.
Even when I got stream sniped at Apex, they were all dog shit!
Why, why do the real gamers exist on Twitch?
Bitch!
All my YouTube snipers are so nice to me!
My YouTube snipers are so nice to me!
My Twitch snipers are mean!
At least they were funny!
At least my YouTube snipers were funny!
Um, um, yeah, so, uh, so, basically, I know, I'm just not used to it.
I'm so not used to being stream sniped on it, like, to this degree.
But, like, everybody on Twitch basically gets stream, like, especially they're, like, in competitive shooting, and in competitive shooting, or, like, just competitive games in general, um, this happens to them, like, almost every stream.
And I'm just, like, I'm just, like, oh my god, I'm not used to it.
I, I don't, I, I'm just not used to it.
I have to, I have to get used to it, but it's, it's so new!
It's, it's so new to me!
Um, anyway, so, here's a funny story about one, remember the Groot guy?
Okay, for those who, okay, for context-wise, for those who didn't watch the Twitch stream yesterday, um, um, we had a stream sniper, um, and he was on Groot, and he was basically throwing, like, he wasn't, like, throwing, but he was, like, bad at being a Groot one trick,
because he couldn't, we were, like, but I didn't say anything about him.
I was just shit-talking the low-key player, because I was, like, what are you doing?
I was, like, why isn't he ulting?
Why did he let me?
I was just, I was shit-talking the low-key player, and then it was only at the end was I was, like, oh yeah, he didn't do any ult combo, like, he, like, the other Groot was clearly better than our Groot, so he got Groot dipped, and then, apparently, he was hate-watching that.
He was watching my stream, and, like, just, like, watching to see my reaction, uh, my reaction to his gameplay, and, like, he thought I was shit-talking him, and I was just, like, I'm, like, what the fuck?
I wasn't, I was, like, I wasn't, and then he, like, blamed him, and, okay, so, context-wise, okay, and then he stream sniped me on the second, and got me again on the second game, and I was watching my stream and reacting to it, and was, like, shit-talking me on,
in, like, in, like, responding to, like, what I was saying on stream, because I don't talk to people.
I keep it in my stream.
I don't say it to the VC, so, like, um, and then, like, he, right after that game, he friended Gomez to talk more shit about me, like, what kind of?
And then, I was, like, what the fuck was he saying?
And you know what he, the, okay, all right, so, he literally was telling him, he was, like, why doesn't she try on stream?
Why is she focused on entertaining her chat and not trying on stream?
And I was, like, excuse me?
The first game wasn't even my fault.
I was trying so hard on my first game, the first game.
I wasn't even the problem in the, he was the problem in the first game.
And I was just, like, I didn't lose as that first game.
The second game, I got tilted, but it wasn't because I was, like, not trying.
I actually got tilted on the second game.
And, like, but then he was, like, um, he was just, like, yelling at Gomez and was, like, I can't believe, like, why doesn't she try?
And I'm, like, bro, even when I'm streaming, I'm still playing better than you.
Oh my god, I was so surprised.
I was just, like, anyway, um, he got reported for stream sniping because apparently it is a bannable offense.
So, like, I don't know if he will get banned, but, like, it was nice that, uh, Gomez reported him to the devs right after.
Um, but, like, I thought that shit was so funny.
I was, like, what?
I was just, like, what are you?
What do you mean?
Why?
Why is she so focused on being an entertainer?
She should be trying, like, all these other pro players.
How dare she be a fucking content creator?
Like, oh my god.
So, um, um, so that's basically, like, what was going on yesterday.
Like, how dare you be?
Oh, I'm sorry for being entertaining.
Well, there's, like, 500 million other streamers out there streaming Marvel Rivals that are doing super try-hard shit.
Like, go watch them if you want.
I'm just trying to be actually entertaining.
Like, if you wanna, I've never tooted my own horn being, like, a pro or anything.
I literally, I literally hit my head against the wall until I figure out how to play the game.
Like, I don't know what the fuck I'm actually doing.
I just play the game.
Like, that shit, that was crazy.
That was such a, like, I think the craziest part is the fact that he friended my duo just to yell at me.
Like, just to yell.
He didn't even friend me.
He friended my duo.
I was like, wait, he friended you?
And that checked my friend list and I didn't even get an ad.
He friended my duo just to talk shit about me.
Yeah, that's so crazy.
I'm like, are you, like, 14?
Like, I'm gonna tell your dad about this.
I'm gonna tell a grown-up about you.
And I'm like, excuse me?
I'm gonna tell a teacher.
I can't fathom yelling at you.
Like, that's so crazy.
But yes, I was indeed getting stream sniped almost every game.
So, like, that's why I, like, knew I'm gonna try and force stack during late night queues and then during, like, actual decent hours.
And I'm playing Marvel Rivals on Twitch.
Then I'll, like, you know, actually, I won't be worried because it's harder to stream snipe me when everybody's fucking queuing at the same time.
So, like, that's basically it.
Okay, another story that I really want to tell you guys.
So, the reason why I was late was because I had, like, a lot of errands to do today.
One of the things is I had to go to the bank and I had to do some bank stuff.
And then, and the reason why I was so late coming back is because I need to find, I had to find a new bank because something happened at the bank where I realized I have to go to another bank now.
So, so, basically, all right, so, I'm okay telling this story because I think this person knows me from streaming on Twitch.
So, basically, I was, I was going, I went to the bank to do some stuff.
And, um, and then I was the bank teller.
I was the bank teller.
And I was like, oh, you know, and my bank, it has my business name.
You see, my account has my business name, right?
So, um, so, and then, like, she came back and was like, hey, one of my co-workers was asking if you knew, knew somebody called something wig.
And I was like, deer in the head.
And I didn't know what, at that time, I was like, what do I say?
I was like, oh, yeah, yeah, I do.
Because, like, I just didn't, I legit, I just didn't know.
But, like, I, it was so out of nowhere.
So, I was just, and lying just didn't come, like, I just couldn't, I, I just, my brain just couldn't go with lying.
Because it was just, it just, I just didn't know.
I was just like, oh, my God.
If the, if she said, like, are you jokey breed?
Or, like, anything else, I would have been able to lie.
But then she was like, do you know this person called something wig?
And then I was just like, I just, because it was such a, it was a question I was not prepared for, at all.
Like, I was not prepared for that one.
So, if it was anything else, I would be prepared.
But this one, I wasn't.
Anyway, so, she didn't know what was going on, because, like, she was like, um, she was just like, oh, my, my co-worker, like, said that.
And then, like, after I was done with my bank stuff, because I was like, okay, it's fine.
The actual bank teller doesn't know who I'm at, who I am.
It's just a co-worker.
It's fine.
And then, and then, after I was done with my bank stuff, I was just, like, packing up my stuff.
And then, this, the guy, the co-worker, approached me and was like, are you Doki Bird?
And I was just like, no.
I just work for her.
I was like, no, I just, I just work for her.
And then, and then, and then, and then they were like, they were like, oh, oh, do you stream?
I was like, no.
She just doesn't like to go to the bank, so I do this for her.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
So, anyway, now, after that, I'm not going back to that bank.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I, I have moved to another bank now.
Like, I, I have, I, I have relocated to a different bank now, because I don't want to show my face at that bank anymore.
I don't, but it's, it's so far away.
And I could never go back.
It's, the other bank is so far away.
So, that's why I was late, because I waited a bit to tell this story, because I was like, I don't want to give them.
So, like, I have, yes, but I think they're a Twitch watcher, because they're like, do you know NiceWig, or do you know NiceWig, basically, because I'm pretty sure they're a Twitch watcher, and that's why I tell this story on YouTube, because sometimes the audiences don't overlap.
And that's the gamble I'm willing to take.
That's, that's the gamble I'm willing to take right now.
So, oh my god.
So, yeah, so I was just like, BankerBro, BankerBro totally not watching the stream, and it's totally not a drag.
JP, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, that's why I was a little late coming back, because, like I said, like, it's a lot further than my, than my old place, but, like, I got, I got scared after that.
I was just like, oh man, like, I don't know if I can show my face, but I don't, I don't know if he believed me.
That's the thing, because after I was like, no, I just work for her, and, like, she doesn't like to go to the bank herself, because she doesn't, she wants her privacy respected.
And, like, I don't think he believed me.
That's the worst part, because he was like, do you, because he asked me if I streamed after I was like, no, I'm not DokiBird, I just work for her.
And then he was like, do you stream, though?
And I'm like, oh, oh, fuck.
I don't know if he does.
I'll never, I'm not risking it, though.
I'm not risking it.
Oh my god, I was so monotone, too.
They were like, I was like, oh no, I just, I work for her.
I, I, uh, she doesn't like to go to the bank.
Like, I was so monotone, like...
I tried so hard to, like, not, like, just be a different, be fucking different.
Um, um, anyway, so that's another story, but not DokiBird is one of your most used tags.
How would they know?
I said I'm not DokiBird.
I fooled some people before I can do it again, but I don't think, I don't think I tricked, I don't, I don't know.
I think he knows.
I, I think, I think he knew the moment I said I wasn't DokiBird.
I think he knew.
Are you DokiBird?
No, I'm not DokiBird.
I ain't worried.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, um, um, anyway, uh, anyway, so that's another story.
So, also, like, I went to get my eyebrows, uh, threaded today, because I haven't, um, I haven't, like, got my eyebrows threaded, like, done.
I, okay, I have a problem with hair, so, like, this only affects my eyebrows, like, my face and head, but I grow hair way too fast, and I grow a lot of hair, so, like, when I get my haircut done, every time, I have to get my haircut done very frequently,
or it gets super thick and super long within a couple of months, like, within, like, a few months, like, two to three months, I have to get my hair cut regularly, so, like, and then I don't have a unibrow.
I just get lots of, I just have a lot, like, it's, like, the volume is a lot, like, thick So, I have to get it, um, I haven't, like, done it recently, and so, like, I was, like, oh, fuck, there's, it's, I, there's too much.
So, like, so, like, this happens for my face and head, so, I have, so, like, um, when I went to get my eyebrows threaded, um, the lady was, like, was, like, oh, my God, I love your eyebrows, there's so much volume, and inside my head, I was, like, that is the problem,
that is the fucking problem.
She's, like, oh, my God, I love working with your eyebrows, there's so much volume.
I'm, like, no, it's not good.
It's...
It's not good, there's too much, and too much hair.
And it's, like, so weird, the rest of my body doesn't have the effect, it's just my fucking face and head, and I'm, like, oh, and every time, every time I, like, finish my haircut, there's, like, a fucking pool of hair, like, if I do haircuts and stuff,
and they'll be, like, wow, your hair is so thick, there's so much volume on your head, and I'm, like, yes, and my head feels so fucking heavy because of it, and then, um, and then they'll be, and then I look down, and it's just, like, it's just hair, it's... I just,
I look down, and it's just fucking hair, it's just a pool of hair, but I still have, like, but it feels like they cut nothing.
Don't keep me waiting for Guanyin.
It doesn't affect my, okay, it doesn't affect my, like, like, lips, upper lips, it's literally my eyebrows.
It's my eyebrows and, like, my hair, like, my upper lip is okay, thank God, like, I don't... Thank fucking God, I'm so happy I don't have to deal with that.
It's literally, it's, like, it's, like, my eyebrows, and I remember, like, um, I remember, like, when I was getting my... I was so self-conscious about my eyebrows because I have thick eyebrows, and then, like, back then, I didn't get, like, I didn't do,
like, thread... I didn't thread my eyebrows for, like, maintenance back then, but I was in, like, high school, so, like, I didn't care as much because I was in, like, I was in middle school, so I was in middle school, so, of course, I didn't care.
I was in fucking middle school, and then, like, I always... but I was always, like, like, semi-self-conscious about it because I just didn't, like, I just didn't like that my eyebrows were really thick, and so, um, so, like, I remember one of my friends who's,
like, an artist, and then she, like, she was doing, like, portraits and stuff, and then she was, like, um, she was, like, drawing me, and then she's, like, oh, I love drawing your eyebrows.
They're so thick.
I'm, like, please don't.
Please.
I'm so uncomfortable.
I'm, like, I'm very uncomfortable.
She's, like, oh, you have such nice thick eyebrows.
It's so nice to draw.
It's so unique to draw.
And I was, like, oh, my God, like, you know, maybe I don't want to be involved in this carcass, like, in this drawing anymore.
I don't want to be involved.
Um, Andy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dookie has some guanyun eyebrows.
No!
Thank you for the, uh, super chat.
Thank you.
Um, anyway, so, so, there's that.
And then, I got really sad because I was, like, oh, man, I'm so excited that I get to go to this place, uh, because it was next to the bank.
I was, like, oh, my God, like, the mall was next to, um, I was, like, oh, yeah, I can go to this mall that's close by.
And, like, it has my favorite ice cream place.
I can't believe this happened twice.
Like, it's actually crazy.
I went to the mall and I was, like, yay, ice cream!
And it was gone.
It was... The store was no more.
This ice cream store was gone.
It wasn't even closed.
It was just gone.
I was, like, I was here last month.
I was, like, not again!
It happened again!
I was, like, yay, ice cream!
And then, it was gone.
And then, again, if I had nickel every time I went to a mall that I never... I haven't been to in a long time just for the ice cream, I'd have two nickels.
It's weird that it happened twice within the year.
Two different ice cream stores!
Two different ones!
Oh, my God.
It was my favorite ice cream store!
My other favorite one.
I had, like, several favorite ice cream stores.
So, uh, bro, we just started the year.
Calm down.
So, that was basically, um, story time for, like, today.
So, very, uh, very exciting and sad day.
Yeah, that's, yeah, it's been, it's been a very exciting and sad day today.
So, I've been, like, very busy.
Yeah, I was very busy in the, in the evening because, like, of all the stuff that was going on and everything.
Uh, but yeah, is there anything else that happened today?
No, it was just that.
I think it was, yeah, it was just that.
Anyway, Dynasty Warriors!
I'm super duper excited to play Dynasty Warriors.
If you guys didn't know about me, um, I grew up with the Dynasty Warrior games since Dynasty Warriors 1.
Um, basically, it was my, me and my dad's favorite game series.
Um, my dad loved Dynasty Warriors and he would buy every game and he would play it with me.
Um, and we would just do, like, uh, uh, we would just, like, you know, we would play co-op together and everything.
Uh, also, Rush, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki, thank you so much for the almost daily apps to brighten our days.
It's my birthday today and I just turned 30.
Is it okay to ask for a birthday greeting for me?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Rush.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Woo!
But yes, um, I started at Dynasty Warriors 1, um, on the PlayStation 1 because my dad was obsessed with it.
And, um, because of it, he would make me play with him Dynasty Warriors.
And I've always loved the, uh, the Romance of the Three Kingdoms story.
It's always been, like, one of the most famous stories in, in China.
And, um, and I've actually read the books.
I've seen the movies.
Um, I've seen the live action adaptations of the Romance of the Three Kingdoms and the Three Kingdoms in general.
And, um, and, um, so it's just, you know, it's, I've had a long history with Dynasty Warriors.
Um, and I also played the, uh, the Strategist one, the Strategies one.
And then they had, like, I think, I'm pretty sure they had, like, crossovers and stuff like that.
I tried to play as many of the spin, many spinoffs of the Dynasty Warriors series.
Um, and, uh, I saw, I saw the Red Cliff movie.
I saw the Red Cliff movie on, um, in theaters.
Uh, um, so, like, it was honestly, I only, I, it was so good.
I remember watching it in theaters when it first came out, um, in, in China.
And it's actually one of my favorite movies.
Uh, but yeah, uh, and, uh, let's see what else can I talk about it.
I used to really like Liu Bei.
I don't anymore because I sort of grew up and realized, I was like, wait a minute, wait a minute.
He's, uh, he's not that good.
I was like, he's not really a good leader.
He's not really, he, he has good people working for him, but he's a terrible leader with a fucking terrible son.
And also because, like, and then he, they made him a baby face.
I actually went to Liu Bei's, um, temple, uh, temple when I, when I was younger.
I went to his temple and, like, his gravesite and everything, and also Cao Cao.
I used to call him Cao Cao, but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna trigger a few people because the English dub of Dynasty Warriors used to call him Cao Cao, and then I would just call him Cao Cao all the time because of it.
And, and I know that's, like, not the right pronunciation of Cao, it's Cao Cao, but I'm gonna call him Cao Cao, guys.
I don't care.
I, I care, but, like, I'm sorry.
I should care.
I should care, but also, like, um, I just, I don't know.
It's just ingrained in my head now.
It's, it's ingrained in my head.
Um, um, but yes, um, I did, I even went to, like, the temples of, um, of Liu Bei and, um, I wrote, actually wrote, like, a paper about Zhuge Liang, uh, Zhuge Liang, Zhuge Liang, and, um, it was really funny because I told the story before, but in high school or,
like, in middle, in, like, ninth grade, I wrote a paper about, uh, Zhuge Liang, uh, Zhuge Liang, and, like, about, because you're, like, choose a person, it was, like, choose a historical figure that you believe should be, um, should, um, that achieved greatness or something.
I don't remember the story.
I don't remember the actual topic, but we just had to choose a historical figure that, like, achieved something great in history.
So I chose him because I was super fucking obsessed with him and... oh, I need to blow my nose.
Sneeze.
And then, um, the thing is, at that time, I didn't really realize how much the books embellished him and the games embellished him.
And that was the day I learned, when I did that paper, that was the day I learned that, like, that, like, they didn't do much.
Because, like, the book and the play, it was, like, a romance of the three kingdoms.
So that's what romance meant.
So, so, like, I found out from, like, it was, they, like, basically, I still love Ju-Gil-Yeon.
I still love him as a character, but not, like, a historical figure anymore.
Yeah, they're, like, historical fantasies.
So, like, you don't really know if, like, some of these things actually happen.
Never research your heroes.
So, so, so, when I, when I was trying, when I was researching him, and, um, I got, like, um, the, the teacher was, like, I believe you think he was of great importance, but he's not really.
I remember that was one of my notes.
It's just, like, it's just, like, I can tell that you think he provided a lot to the world, but in reality, he didn't actually.
I'm, like, oh, man.
A sad reality.
A community noted by teacher.
Oh, the heart is true.
Zane, my childhood was a lie, but he was so cool.
He was the actor for him.
For him, Redcliffe was so hot, too.
He looked so cool in every media adaptation.
What do you mean?
He wasn't actually cool.
What do you mean he didn't do all of these things?
So, um, so anyway, so that's basically my history with Dynasty Warriors.
So, I'm very excited to...
I'm very excited to try the game out.
Apparently, people are saying that the newest game is, um, is actually really good compared to the last one, which isn't saying much because the last one I'm sorry.
Please don't.
Please don't hurt me, Japan.
Please don't hurt me.
Is it Konami, please?
It's a pretty low bar.
Oh, my God.
Koei, sorry.
Koei.
I was like, oh, my God.
It starts with K.
I was like, it starts with K.
Koei, please.
I'm sorry.
I love your games.
But, like, anyway, um, um, it's not a high bar in terms of, like, being an improvement to, like, to, like, the last game.
So, so, I, I'm excited.
I am really excited.
We haven't had Dynasty Warriors game in a very, in a while.
I think, when was the last Dynasty Warriors game?
It's been a long time because the reception for the last one wasn't the greatest.
So, people were, so, they, like, held out on creating a new Dynasty Warriors for the longest time.
So, like, um, yeah, it's been a long, long, long time since they made a new one.
So, I'm super excited.
I cannot wait to basically go through the, the, what was it called?
Oh, my God.
It's been so, I can't wait to become sworn brothers again and then pursue Lu Bu and, um, and then, um, and then do the Red Cliff all over again and then watch, uh, Lu, and then watch, uh, uh, Zhuge Liang trying to fucking salvage the Shu empire, but he can't because Lu Bei's son is a fucking,
what, how do I phrase this nicely?
He is worthless.
He is, he is not, but you guys didn't know, um, the reason why Lu Bei's son is, like, uh, worthless is because Lu, apparently, I'm not sure if it's true or if this was romanticized, but Lu Bei dropped his son on his head.
So, like, and then he became the leader after Lu Bei died and I was just like, oh, no, that's a good idea.
Like, I don't know.
I don't, I don't know.
That's me saying it nicely.
Apparently threw him and twice.
So, like, but then he ended up becoming the leader afterwards.
So, um, yeah, no wonder the Shu empire fucking never took off.
It never, it never took off in the end.
Um, but yeah, I'm super excited.
Uh, all right, booting up the game.
I hope my sound guys, sound guys are here.
Uh, isn't supported.
Oh, wait, my DualSense, do I have to use my Xbox controller?
It says my DualSense controller isn't supported, so I'll get my, I'll get my Xbox controller and see if it's better.
I don't know.
Okay, does my Xbox controller work?
Sorry, I'm like trying to see which controller.
Oh, it is.
Okay.
All right.
No, it says for Dynasty Warriors, it doesn't work like that.
Uh, no, I agree.
And then, um, after that, my favorite kingdom was, um, um, I guess it was Wu after that, because is it Wu?
Um, I, I like, I like certain characters in different kingdoms.
So, um, um, maybe, um, I used to like Wu.
I used to like Wu.
And I guess because of, what's her name?
Sun Shan Shan?
The, the girl.
Sun Shan Shan.
But then I found out that she didn't do much in actuality.
Don't research your heroes.
Because she was my favorite.
She was, I would play her since Dynasty Warriors 1.
I would always play her, because I loved her character.
But then I found out that she was like a nobody.
She was like, she had, don't research your heroes.
Like...
And then I got so sad.
I was like, what are you trying to tell me?
She actually had no significant importance in, in the story.
They only put her in the game because she was a girl and they needed a girl character in the Dynasty Warriors.
They made up things about her.
Like,
they made up stuff about her in the games that I thought was real.
And I was like, what do you mean she didn't do all this?
The bitter truth.
She had to be the girl in the game, because they needed girls in the game.
But she had no significant importance.
I thought she was so cool.
And I was like, oh my god, she's so cool.
Oh my god, I want to be just like her.
Don't research your heroes.
Don't, don't research your heroes.
No, the game is historically canon.
It keeps hurting every time you say it.
Yeah, but at that time, when I was younger, I was like, so obsessed with like, with her.
She was literally the only character I would play.
For like, the first three to four games, for the first three games, I would only play her and I would play her storyline.
And I thought her storyline was true.
I was like, her storyline is real to me.
I thought her story was true.
I played her storyline and everything.
And then...
No, but the English dub is so funny.
I'm sorry.
I grew up with the English dub and it's so funny.
I love, I'm sorry.
I actually love the English dub.
You don't understand.
It's actually one of my, one of my favorites from Dynasty Warriors.
It's legitimately the English dub.
It's one of my, it's actually like one of my favorite parts about Dynasty Warriors.
Yeah, they like, I'm so sorry.
I know it's like, they like butcher names.
Um, they butcher names.
They like, the dubbing is like super silly sometimes, but that's what makes it peak.
It's, it's peak to me.
Um, Gambit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was real to me.
How else would I hear Lupe talk about benevolence for the 800th time?
How else?
It's the only way to play the game.
All right.
All right, perform initial setup.
Yes.
It's so iconic.
Exactly.
You know, that power of my match.
I love like, oh, what was the, the yellow?
Um, how is it called?
The yellow, it's been so long since I've...
Three kingdoms.
The yellow rebellion.
I love like, the leader of the yellow rebellion's voice actor.
Um, the yellow turban.
Yeah, the, what was the leader's name?
I love his voice in the English dub, because it's so fucking silly.
Like, it's, it's so silly whenever, um, whenever he talks and he's like, I'm gonna curse you.
It's legit, and it makes me so happy.
That's why I love the English dub.
It's actually, it's actually one of my favorite shit.
I wish I talked like him.
Um, let's see.
Does that even change?
All right.
All right, here we go.
It's you?
Oh, oh my God, it's CGI.
Promise you what?
Oh, it's so pretty.
Yeah, the CGI looks really beautiful.
Why is Brokhan a cute doll?
That's me, right?
Yeah, I'm the nameless hero.
Year six of the Guan He era, or 150 years since the start of the Eastern Hong dynasty.
Oh, I love... Zhang He was my dad's favorite character.
Him, it was him and Xiaohudun, which is funny because they're so different from each other.
Zhang He and Xiaohudun, um, was my dad's favorite characters.
They're like two sides of a coin.
A drought that's been ongoing since the previous years and barrage of inclement weather resulted in devastating famine.
The people were starving, resulting to eating grass.
They're gonna- oh my God, they're gonna eat grass?
What a miserable place.
Unfortunately, Xiaohudun is like almost everybody's favorite character.
Because he looked so cool.
He had one eye.
He had an eye patch.
So fucking cool.
And he had a giant ass sword.
Guan Yun?
Why you look like that?
Why does he have short hair?
He's young.
I like how he's young, but he still has his glorious beard.
So hungry.
We're so hungry.
Pro is 30?
What do you mean?
That is not like young, like young, young.
Oh no, not the child!
Oh my God.
If you are 30 and you can grow a beard like that, that's fucking cool.
Why it's me?
I'm so cool.
Oh my God, look at that.
I could do that.
Yeah, if you're 30.
No, I mean like back then in like ancient China, you can grow to old age.
Unlike like, unlike Europe, because you guys had the plague.
I mean, it doesn't help that at that time, Europe was going through like several plagues and they were like shitting outside.
And...
You're fair enough.
Who are you, long-haired man?
Oh my God, the BGM is so, so nostalgic, guys.
The... oh my God.
Oh, that is my Dynasty Warriors BGM right there!
There it is!
Oh my God, you're so cool, Guan Yun!
I hope nothing bad happens to you in battle!
Oh, man!
He's so cool.
There's no way anything bad's gonna happen to him, especially in battle, resulting in any betrayal.
Don't visit anymore!
It's okay, he's still poor Shadow.
That sure would be sad.
There's no way.
I hope he's not gonna get backstabbed anytime soon!
That would never happen, right?
And then your sworn brothers all suffer a terrible fate too, but that's not gonna happen.
I hope he never loses his head.
I mean... not soon, soon!
Don't spoil the story!
Oh, the story that's been, like, retold, like, 20,000 times!
Oh, man!
Not... not that story!
Okay, nice.
Defense is the key?
This is Dynasty Warriors, there's no defense here!
But it's new to me!
What I love is that Dynasty Warriors can retell the story, like, they can make Dynasty Warriors 50 and I'll still buy the game.
They can retell the Yellow Turban War to me, like, 500 times and I'll still be like...
Be afraid of my magic!
That's true loyalty!
Oh, evade!
Okay, true!
We just eat it up!
Okay, L-Y-Y... wait, what?
Oh, okay, so this is a stronger attack.
The power of the heavens!
I'll be like, say the line!
I'll be, like, 80 and I'll boot up Dynasty Warriors and he would be like... I'll be like, say the line!
Say the line, Lupe!
And I'll be like, for benevolence!
I'll be like, yay!
Same, same!
I'll be like, this is where they become...
We are back in the fucking gardens.
This is where they become... I'll be like, chat children!
This is where they become...
Become sworn brothers!
What is this?
You're out of luck!
This is where you scoundrels meet your end!
That can't be right!
I just started this game, so I know I'm gonna live!
We may be outnumbered, but we must not falter!
Oh, who's that?
Who's that?
I don't need a name.
Is that Jack?
Is that...
Wait, that's Jengel?
What happened to your silly voice?
No, he's hot!
Oh my god!
For the first time, they made him hot!
I don't know how to feel about this!
Holy shit!
Wait, he's hot now!
What a clone!
The wizard is not silly anymore!
He isn't old and silly!
Oh my god!
He is!
Look, he does look like Jack!
Jesus!
Oh my god!
Why is he hot?
What about the magic?
Holy shit!
Where is all of this?
That shit-shot looks like that!
Oh no!
He made him hot!
That's actually crazy!
I did not expect that to be him!
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
Not gonna lie though, I don't really want to play as a nameless hero.
I think the fun- the most fun- oh nice!
Musou attack!
I think like the most fun part about Dynasty Warriors- okay, where's my bow?
I need bread!
I need- I don't- I need bread right now!
I need- I'd rather- I want to play as like- I want to play Guan Yu!
Let me handle this for now.
I need Mantle.
Oh my god, Guan Yu!
Oh!
Deathwing!
Deathscore!
Yes!
Insane!
That's fucking right!
The game heard me!
Let's go!
Oh my god, he heard me!
I was like, I want to play Guan Yu!
He's like, all right, Ben, here you go!
I willed it into existence!
It's the newest patch!
Ask and you shall receive!
Look at me go!
I'll never die and I'll have my head!
My head will always be a part of my body!
That's so oddly specific, but I just want you guys to be sure!
I just want you guys to know that for sure!
I know it's very oddly specific, but don't worry!
Oh wait, what's my Musou attack?
Nice!
Why?
What an oddly specific thing to say, Doki!
900.
Oh wait, I don't want to beat him!
I don't- where's my Mantle?
Where is it?
Oh, I'm so fucking- Oh, this is bad.
This is actually- Oh!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
How is there no bread?
What do I do?
I don't have bread!
I don't- Ha, Chen Xiao!
Go, go kill him!
But Dynasty Warriors was never about defense!
It was never about defense when-
Guys, don't you know that?
Dynasty Warriors never did anything about defense!
So like- Oh my god, he's getting closer.
He's getting closer!
Oh nice!
Oh my god, yes!
1 HP and a dream!
Welcome back to difficulty!
There we go.
I did it.
I told you I can do defense.
Just don't die, streamer.
Kalsi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I believe he's hot now.
It is him!
He has the staff!
Wait, it is him!
Oh my god!
My silly wizard!
Bad knight!
Hello, Guan Yun.
It's nice to see you alive and well.
Of course!
That's how he gain f- Guan Yun!
You didn't actually tell it to him because of the beard.
Without even asking your name.
Tell me, what are you called?
Um, we all know.
Okay, there we go.
How could they know?
I cannot tell you!
How would they know?
How naturally!
The bank people definitely didn't know.
You will be called Nod Doheed.
Do you wish to proceed?
Yes.
Hmm.
I don't know.
That is quite intriguing.
Where could I be from?
You fought with such effortless skill.
I've never seen anything like it.
I'm curious to know where you trained.
It's the same answer.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
It's I've forgotten and I can't remember.
Like, I feel like I should say it.
It's the same one.
It's the same answer.
Um, I forgot.
So you have no memory of your past?
I hit my head.
My dad dropped- my dad threw me on the ground twice.
In any case, it was fortunate I met you when I did.
Most wandering warriors won't lift a finger until they hear talk.
Whoa, Nod Doheed, I saw you at the bank.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know and I really like the color green.
But you are not like the others.
I see you walk an honorable path wielding your blade for the weak.
I was told to do so.
I think I should be on the other side of the- oh my god, guys.
I know it's gonna look weird, guys.
Guys, don't be weird about this.
But I think I have to be on the- I know it's gonna- I know you're not used to this, guys.
But I think I actually have to be on the other side.
I-
Left side doki.
I think I have to be left side doki for today.
Don't- don't be weird about this, guys.
Don't be.
I'm scared of change.
What?
Of like corruption?
You mean like the rest of the world?
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My question is, is John Fae hot too?
Thank you for the super chat.
I mean, his daughter's hot.
I don't even know if that's also romanticized.
Perhaps this is heaven's way of lamenting the state of the land.
The heavens feel sadness?
The will of the heavens is absolute.
Oh, and the yellow turbans?
Their ranks are growing rapidly.
Their promises of a brighter future must be drawing in the powerless masses.
I've spoken too much.
It is already grown late.
Wow, actually decent pronunciation.
Yeah, they got better at it after like the fourth game.
Yeah, because it was so weird because like they used to call him Cao Cao.
And then I didn't realize his real name was actually Tao Tao because my dad never explained it to me, even though he was like, he's like full Chinese.
And like, so like he'd also call him Cao Cao.
So I thought that was real.
And then after the fourth game, they suddenly changed his name to Tao Tao.
And I was like, what is this?
I was like, why did they change his name?
This is not historically accurate, but like...
I was a fool, because before then it wasn't historically accurate.
And then they try to be historically accurate.
A country that has long been divided will reunite.
One that has long been united will become divided.
Long ago, the Han dynasty was founded by Emperor Gaozu and re-established by Emperor Guangfu.
Who the fuck are you?
You were never in my dad's stories.
Heaven's will is now clear.
The coming age will inevitably be one of great chaos.
Who invaded this child?
That is why.
You must bring peace to the world.
Me?
Not Doki?
I'm gonna unite the three kingdoms?
Rise now, guardian of peace.
Oh my God, you're gonna see me in the history books.
That's... Dual Si?
Wait, is that actually...
I'm the chosen... I've always known I was the chosen one, guys.
There's no way that's...
They made him into a giant!
They made him!
There's no way!
I love the CGI.
It's so pretty though.
The CGI is really beautiful.
Oh.
Yeah, it looks really, really good.
I love the CGI.
Wait, am I going... Is this the intro now?
Did I just finish the tutorial?
Some poor kid is going to do a report in three kingdoms.
Hero, not Doki.
I hope you're happy with yourself.
Papa smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's me, I'm remembering my first battle.
Oh my God.
Oh, the classic.
Oh, the classic intro!
Oh my God!
Let's fucking go!
I love the intros.
The intros are my favorite.
Oh my God, there he is.
He's finally old now.
Oh my God, that's Redcliffe!
It's not Zhao Yun!
Yeah!
Do not pursue Lu.
Guys, oh my God, I'm Zhao Yun now!
Oh my God, it's Zhao Yun!
Koei's like, goodbye Zhao Yun.
I'm done playing with you.
Oh my God, fucking finally!
A major upheaval began.
By extending a hand to suffering peasants, the Way of the Great Peace gained immense support.
Zhang Zhao, the movement's founder.
Do not pursue- what are you doing?
In aid of the provinces, countless adherents of the Way of the Great Peace- This is what I don't understand.
For some reason, Koei fucking loves Zhao Yun.
Like, they put him in everything.
They're like- It's like- He's literally in every cover and like, intro.
He's like- yeah, he's the poster boy.
He's like, he's so handsome.
He has to be everywhere.
Heroes rise in the midst of turmoil.
Two months after the Yellow Turbans uprising.
He was my dad's favorite character, too.
It was Zhao- Just because like, he was everywhere.
I feel like my dad only liked him because he was everywhere.
And Zhao Yun was like, overpowered as hell, too.
What the fuck?
I'm Godzilla.
You journey through this vast world on your own two feet.
Your path shall become clear through numerous encounters and- I did not expect this part.
I was like, what the fuck?
I did not expect this part of the game.
I'm big now.
This is interesting.
Yeah.
Historically accurate size.
That's me.
How could- but the linear's hot!
If cruel, why hot?
So you have Jean?
Oh, it's time to fight the Yellow Turb- but we fought together!
Me and him and Guan Yun!
We fought together!
How could he be evil?
No way!
Homies for life!
There's no backstabbing during the three- I can't even say that in a serious face.
Everybody backstabbed.
There was no actual friends...
during this time.
Bro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There was so much backstabbing.
I'm not afraid.
That's right.
That's me.
Oh my god, Mercenary?
No, come on, girl!
Gossip!
Who's gonna know?
I won't snitch you...
to the- to the General.
But never!
Anyway, what's your name- full name and designation?
Who is the governor?
Yeah, who is he?
Oh, I see.
He was dismayed by the chaos and turmoil, so he's raising an army to defeat the Yellow Turbans.
A truly great man.
Tell me about this force.
It's a small army of volunteers recruited to fight the Yellow Turbans.
Who are growing bolder and more unruly by the day.
What are you doing?
I remember when everyone believed the way of the Great Peace would make the world a better place.
Alright, that's enough questions.
Well, the day's still young.
Once you've unpacked, I suggest you visit the town.
Now, if you will excuse me.
Alright, it's time to explore the town.
I already like this more than the last game.
The last game felt so empty.
Especially like...
The CGI was not the best too.
The inn acts as a base during your travels.
Letters may arrive from time to time.
Reading letters allows you to learn what's going on in the world and can sometimes advance the story.
Who wrote to me?
The Yellow Turbans, selling chaos throughout the realm, are now descending upon Yo's province.
Local government...
Okay, so that's...
Has been decreed that those who fight to bring order to the realm...
Shall be provided with gold.
Oh my god, I love gold.
Oh my god, there we go.
I haven't done anything yet.
But like, I already got 10,000 gold.
I feel like you should pay before...
After...
Cause like...
If you pay them now...
What if they just die?
Like...
I don't know.
Is that just me?
I feel like I should be paid after...
I survive.
Yay!
Signing bonus!
Nameless warrior garb.
Oh wait, isn't that...
I pre-ordered this.
Isn't this...
Wukong's outfit?
Apparently, if you pre-order it...
I think like...
They did like a collaboration with Wukong.
Oh, Wolong?
Oh, it's Wolong?
Oh my god!
Nevermind.
Wrong Wu.
Wrong one.
Wolong, yeah.
I was like thinking...
I saw Wu and I was like...
Oh, Wukong!
And I was like...
Oh, it's Wolong.
And like, I fucking misread.
Like, I misread it.
Close enough.
I never played Wolong.
Wolong.
Is it good?
I was thinking about...
Monkey.
I don't know if I should change...
I want the original clothes for now.
Alright, let's go out.
Time to go outside.
Peaches!
Peach, please.
Oh!
Please, sir.
I'm so hungry.
What is this subtitle?
No!
Don't do crime!
Crime does not pay!
Is that jump...
No way!
That's...
That's jumping!
No way!
No!
I recognize those muscles anywhere!
I...
Why is he hot and fat?
Hi.
Is that Lupe?
Oh my god, please tell me you have a mustache.
Please tell me you must...
Don't be babyface!
Do not be babyface, Lupe!
I swear to god!
No!
What is he...
Oh my god!
What the fuck!
What is he...
You're right, your lips is not long enough.
Oh my god!
What is...
Yeah!
Oh my god, he looks like a celeb.
He looks like...
He looks like the actor from Red Cliff!
Wait!
Okay, dude.
He actually looks like the actor from...
He looks like a fucking celeb.
Okay, I need to show you guys what he looks like.
I was like, wait a minute.
He looks just like him.
Yeah!
He looks like...
Um...
Wait!
Oh my god!
But like, without...
He does!
He does look like him!
Oh my god, why does he look like him?
Why does...
Okay, this is what he looks like to me.
This is the actor for Chocolat in the Red Cliff.
And I was like, oh my god, I always remember.
Because I was like, oh, he's so hot as Chocolat.
And I was like...
I was like, oh my god, he's so hot.
It looks just like him!
Like, it actually...
It actually looks...
It actually looks just like him!
Oh my god!
It's him!
I can't believe...
Oh my god, why does he...
Where's your mustache, Lupe?
Where is it?
And also, why is Jon fake?
Why does...
It's so weird that they're all so hot now!
First they made Silly Wizard hot wizard!
And then...
Okay, let me get a drink.
Sorry.
I need a drink.
I need to get my lemon Dongling Cha.
I ordered Dongling Cha, and I...
Oh, and I walked...
I need to get my Dongling Cha.
My lemon tea.
I just...
Oh my god, everybody's hot now.
And it's so weird.
I'm not used to this.
I'm used to them being like, cool and like...
Like, you know, cool and old and...
And like...
Old and stuff.
Alright.
I love Guan...
Oh, Guan Yin!
Remember me?
From tips to twinks.
He came in weird.
Yes.
I can't!
He's so...
I can't.
He's so fucking buff.
Like...
Those muscles.
Ah, ah.
Those arms can feed a village.
Don't thirst over Zhang Fei, guys.
He's an alcoholic.
Like, an extreme alcoholic.
You think like...
You know...
He's like a really, really bad alcoholic.
Look at this.
The eldest!
He's the eldest!
Yeah, by the way, Lu Fei's the eldest.
How is he the eldest?
I can't!
It's an unimpressive, but you know...
I don't want him to have a big ego, guys.
He has really, really good genes.
So cute.
Yeah!
Us three!
Yeah, his earlobes aren't long enough.
I hope like, over time, over the game time, they just make his earlobes longer and longer.
But like, by like...
By like 0.1 centimeter every scene, so we don't notice until it's just like, wait a minute.
I'm rewriting history.
I'm gonna be the forks-worn brother.
Yeah, his beard isn't full yet.
So I'm pretty sure it could happen.
I understand.
Someone will get hurt and it's not gonna be me.
Oh my god, I can't.
Like, I...
His arm is the size of his fucking head.
I can't.
I'm gonna beat the alcoholic.
Alright, let's go.
He has them genes.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I learned how to do this.
Boom!
Oh.
Wait, is he just gonna let me do that?
Oh, it's another tutorial?
I just got back from my tutorial.
Oh yeah?
Boom, I broke your guard.
That's right.
Oh man.
Tutorial 2.
Is he a wooden sword?
Why is my sword so rusty?
Okay.
What's this?
Oh wait, no.
I beat.
Okay.
And then, Falcon Fury.
Bonus art consumes bravery.
Increases as you attack enemies.
Okay.
So I just get more...
Alright, let me get more bravery real quick.
That's fucking right.
Oh yeah?
If I'm weak, why am I just hitting you?
Jungfei.
That's enough for today, don't you think?
Yeah.
Yeah, are you done getting your ass kicked?
That's fucking right.
Oh yeah?
I have a block button.
What you gonna do?
That's fucking right.
Get blocked.
Oh, get blocked again.
That's right.
What else am I gonna do next?
Am I gonna block?
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Wait, what?
I blocked.
Oh.
Oh!
It's like Dark Souls!
Guys, I'm never gonna use that.
You know that, right?
Parry.
What the fuck is that?
Very vague.
Alright, nice.
Alright, come on.
Do your thing again.
That's right.
I don't even have to time it.
I can just spam it.
Come on.
I don't need a tutorial.
Let me beat him up.
Oh shit.
Never mind.
Okay, now I can.
Alright, nice.
That's fucking right.
Defeat John Fae.
Oh, I got this.
I got this now.
Oh.
What?
Fuck!
Okay.
What?
He gets to do that?
That should be illegal.
Oh shit.
I already learned.
I forgot how to...
Oh!
I forgot everything.
That's okay.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Come on.
Wait.
He was shielding this entire time?
What do you mean he was shielding this entire...
Oh, wait.
How did I do that?
Don't!
I wasted it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
What?
What kind of move is that?
Oh my god.
That's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
That's not fair.
He uses Musou.
That's cheating.
That's actually cheating.
I can't believe he uses Musou.
This is a 1v...
This is Final Destination.
No Musou.
No items.
No mantas.
No Musou.
Final Destination.
No Musou Lupu only.
Why?
Why is Lupe so hot?
Is that the only thing he has for him?
Other than benevolence?
But...
He's so hot.
They're all so hot.
We'll know when we see...
Cow-Cow.
We must stop...
We must stop them.
If everyone is hot, Then no one is.
Someone's like.
Oh, Cow-Cow is pretty hot.
Someone... Oh, man!
What did they do to him?
What did they do to KaoKao?
Oh, man!
Unlock.
What is this?
I played the demo.
Oh, oh, it's fast travel.
Hello.
Alright, time... Alright, maybe we'll see you in here.
I can't.
I can't take Lupe, seriously.
Like, even the last game, he still looked a little older.
Like, at this one, he's like... He's like a child.
He's like a teenager.
I've made my decision.
I won't build up tension, guys.
That's me.
I'm part of the team!
I'm part of the gang!
Now, there's four.
History says there were three, but there was actually four.
Oh, cool!
Oh,
this is how I play Dynasty Warriors.
It might not be, like, super fun for some people.
But I literally bone rush into, like, the generals, kill them, and then go next.
Not the main general, but I kill every mini-boss, every of the small generals, and then I go straight for him.
Like, I don't even care about the little guys.
Help people who need it most.
You know, some people actually fight the non-bosses.
Like, the mini-guys.
That, you know, like the red over here that blocks everything.
Some people actually fight those.
I don't.
I just go...
Kill this guy.
Kill him.
And then...
And then go him.
I, like, ignore all these.
I just run- I ride my horse straight through all these guys.
Yeah, I'm a long mower.
Okay, war council.
Battle preparation begin battle.
Alright, I'm ready.
Exactly!
Fodder fights fodder!
I don't need to waste my time on these little people.
They are irrelevant to me.
And nothing bad is ever gonna happen to us.
And we will all grow old and die together.
Right, brothers?
Right, guys?
We're all gonna get our happily ever after.
So specific.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, who the fuck was- Oh, it's Guan Yun.
Of course, nevermind.
Oh, he did- He did the pose!
Guys, did you see that?
He did the Guan Yun pose!
I like how he's- Wait, why is he bigger?
Guys!
Why is he bigger than them?
Oh my god!
To be a general, you must be six feet.
You must- You are just short.
I feel like- Oh shit.
Oh fuck, I need a- I actually need a- Okay, I'm gonna start- I'm actually gonna start blocking too.
Come on.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna ki- Wait, I already killed him.
It's fine.
Oh no.
I don't need to fucking evade when you're already dead!
Mu- Mu Yang Yi is advanced- Okay, I need to find some bows.
Is there any mantas?
Are now advancing to the yellow- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
They're all running for him.
Yeah, the classic dialogue delay.
That's how- Like, why is he so big?
I love how- I love how fucking big they are.
It's like actually- In order to be a general, it's a height requirement.
That's fucked up.
Pressing- I don't need- I don't need to use it.
He's too, like, small.
He's too much of a small fry for me to use it.
That's fucking right.
The secret yells at you must be this tall to be a general.
The fe- Where's the jars?
I need- I need bread.
I'm gonna steal it.
Kill steal!
Oh, I have it!
Oh, it's over here!
Okay, meat buns can be found inside the pots.
Don't worry.
Kill steal!
Nice.
I did it.
He eats good food.
That's why he's bigger.
I need to find pots, though.
Wait, where?
One step closer to victory.
I'm coming over.
Oh my god, he's a magician!
That's for work.
Get out!
No magic allowed!
Only sword fights!
That's right!
You're trying to use filthy magic?
Okay, nice.
Where am I?
Oh god, I have to climb the ladder.
Guys, give me a sec.
I gotta climb the ladder.
I flew too far.
Oh shit.
Oh no, that's not who I wanted.
I flew too far.
Bring a fan into us or get out of here.
No!
The volunteer soldier killed him!
I did all the work!
I can't believe a regular guy killed him.
And it didn't even matter.
Wait, I gotta help him.
I'm gonna get more general kills.
Don't worry.
It's He-Man!
Don't worry, I'm gonna kill He-Man.
Okay.
Oh shit.
That's alright, I blocked it.
I fucking blocked it.
It's fine.
Oh, no!
No, no, no, no!
He-Man, what is he doing here?
Okay, I gotta do this.
I need to remember how to dodge.
Alright, I'm brutal.
Struggle?
Where?
Oh no!
No, no, no!
I got a bun!
No, no, no, no!
It's not fair!
He has a giant hammer!
I just have a sword!
Okay, he should be dead.
One of my favorite characters, He-Man.
I need to find more pots.
I swear, I haven't found a single pot.
Don't worry, I saved you.
Oh, there it is.
I need to keep Dario.
We got two buns.
Open the door.
Alright, guys.
Open the door!
Or we could go the other side, to be fair.
I could just climb this ladder.
I think it would be faster.
I think it would be...
Wait, you're right!
The soldiers actually stay on the ground.
You're right, I just noticed that.
What are you talking about?
Who exactly are you trying to save?
Wait, there's two of them.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god, I'm learning how to dodge!
No, I didn't mean to use my musou!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine, I don't need it to kill the big man.
You guys, you guys open the door while I go the other way.
Making them a force to be reckoned with.
Soldiers of high courage will perform group attacks using tactics?
They're gonna use strategy against me?
Cannot be blocked and can only be stopped with special arts.
Special arts?
Holy shit, he's fucking huge!
What the fuck?
He's bigger than the regular generals!
What is wrong with him?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Bro, what are they feeding him?
What are they feeding these generals?
Simply fed better.
Other villagers?
Bro, this man is 7 feet.
He's not even 6 feet anymore.
They stole all the food.
That's fucking right.
Don't worry, I've gotten you in here too.
Oh shit!
Get parried!
Get fucking parried!
Oh!
Ending it right now.
That's why the people are starving.
Cinema.
We're too early for the NBA.
We're just in time to become a general.
No wonder they are starving.
Yay!
Oh, I can upgrade my sword.
I'm gonna upgrade my sword.
I guess the more I kill, the stronger I become.
The more skills I unlock.
Wait, what does that mean?
That's not controller.
That's not... Okay, it's X.
Guys, oh my god.
That's a really hard combo.
Oh my god, guys.
Do you think I can do this combo?
X, X, X, X, X, X.
Damn.
I don't know, man.
Feels a little difficult.
No.
You're right, I might have to practice.
God, they innovated so much from the original game.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they added an extra X to our combo.
Innovation right there.
Yuan Shao?
Oh, Lu Xia... No, not Lu Xia.
The other Lu.
Oh my god, Jonathan.
You always want to drink.
How is this a celebration of you're always drinking?
Yeah, Lu Yang.
This one's a little bit more special, Doki.
Alright, let's enable Zhang Fei's alcohol problem.
Winning a battle and quelling the chaos will increase the province's level of peace.
Raising priests to high levels brings many benefits.
Ooh, peace has risen!
Nice!
Toggle and break to get access to more precise information.
Use it to find objectives.
Yeah?
Oh, so...
It just says G.
That's it.
That's my extra information.
So extra.
Do I just go... Oh, what's this though?
Oh nice, I found money!
Alright.
Back home!
I have a magic talisman.
Who are you?
At the moment, that light represents the hopes of the people.
Hope provides people with the will to live, and with that determination, they can change the world.
Eventually, this cycle will guide the realm toward peace.
I believe this is also connected to your forgotten past.
That is the very reason why you were entrusted with bringing about an age of peace.
Me?
I'm gonna unite the three kingdoms?
In the end, you will even regain your memories of me in this form.
Who are you, little boy?
Who are you?
It is time for you to go.
Your true journey has now begun.
There's no fucking way!
He's supposed to be old!
Why is he a little boy?!
Ah, I didn't know you had returned.
There's no way.
It can't be.
Oh, I just forgot to take my meds.
Are you okay?
You seem a little dazed.
I suppose you must be tired.
Sorry, I just forgot to take my meds again.
We've just purchased quality incense from the herb shop.
Oh, oh no, never mind.
It might be the incen- Sorry, it might- No, you know what?
No, it's definitely the incense.
I think there's something extra in there.
Ah, I'm sorry.
Oh, that explains it.
Alright, do I have any new letters?
Greetings, NotDoki.
This is my first letter to you.
I'm a volunteer soldier who- Oh, guys!
I have someone who has a crush on me!
And I was saved by your actions.
To be honest, I thought of you as a distant and tribal individual.
But now I wish to hate myself for being- Oh my god, my first fan mail!
Guys, my first fan mail in my P.O.
box!
I saw you throw that enemy soldier who had me cornered right into the air.
And skip through the battlefield from one end to the other to help my comrades.
At that moment, I realized what an incredible officer you will become.
And how your renown will grow amid these dark times.
This is a gift, a small token of gratitude from this unnamed soldier.
I hope- Oh my god, the first dragoon.
Guys, we're doing it.
The very first dragoon.
Alright, uh... Do I need battle preparation anything?
Do I have anything?
No, I don't.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, hey, it's plus two.
I like that.
It has a two on there.
It makes it stronger.
The first- The very first- Your ancestor.
You mean- Alright, John Fae, what do you want?
That was basically a super chat.
Thank you for the super chat, unnamed soldier.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Dookie.
Hey, not Dookie.
Sorry, hey, not Dookie.
What?
I mean, look at his beard.
You've only just heard- Jesus Christ, I'm so rude.
And that's how I'm gonna- And that's how I'm gonna make it.
It's weird listening to John Fae not have a super raspy voice.
They literally just met and was like, we have so much in common, let's be brothers.
I've always wanted a brother.
Don't worry, history will never make fun of you.
Stop!
Oh no.
This is how dude friendships work.
Hey, I love fighting.
I love fighting, too.
Oh my God, samsies, let's be sworn brothers forever.
Not real.
Did we just became sworn brothers?
No need for compli- You're not being very clear.
Why is both my options so fucking bad?
Like, they're so bad.
Like, they're both like, fuck off.
Like, no need for compliments, you're not being- Get this damn bread.
I'm sorry, the other option was just as bad.
It was just as bad, John Fae.
That's why no one talks about you.
This is why they wrote me out of history, guys.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was such an asshole that they literally just wrote me out of history.
I just ceased to exist.
Because I was hated by everyone.
Alright, there are weapon shops, inns, and other collect- locations for you to make use of.
Alright.
Like here?
When I went to G, it literally said nothing about that.
How do I get out of here?
The first time I met my best friend, we just...
We... What?
The crap of each other and we hang- Oh.
What?
We fu- Wait, what is JCK?
The crap of each other and we hanged out after that.
What?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, there's the weapon shop.
You what?
Zion, which weapon is right for you?
Well, I can only buy one.
Your MC was dropped on the head as a baby.
They're clearly- I don't want.
Cholo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I wanna equip it.
Now I can use a sphere.
I should have a longer range now.
Meet Nadoki, the man who unite the three kingdoms to a common hate for him.
For him.
Thank you for the super chat, Raging.
Thank you.
I think I wanna use the sphere.
Just cause it's like, the range is longer.
Got the sphere now.
We got some time to kill until Liu Bei returns.
You can have some fun with those.
There are yellow turbans, remnants all over the place.
Why not go and take them on?
I'm gonna teach you how to use that.
It's all on the wrist.
You'll see.
Just give it a try.
What skirmish has broke out?
It can be concluded in a short period of time.
Skirmishes make for great practices.
Uh, okay, sure.
I'm sorry.
I keep forgetting to move my cursor.
Beat the crap out of each other.
I didn't read it properly.
It's okay.
I was like, whoa!
That is one very unfortunate typo you got there.
Oh, Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, whoa there, Warren.
Sure, Warren.
Sure.
Typo.
Alright, where's the general?
Where's the six foot man?
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
I'm coming for you.
Holy shit, he's fucking huge!
There he is!
Alright, that's fine.
I'm gonna use the new combo I learned.
It's X, and then- It's X, and then X, and then X, and then- Oh wait, an extra Y.
The absolute unit.
Yeah, I was gonna say, this looks like Dao Yun's moveset right there.
Cause he uses a spear too.
Yeah!
What combo did I- Okay, that's also X.
Oh, so like each weapon has its own combo.
I see.
Might as well just use- Yeah, I'll upgrade the spear.
Okay.
Reaching- Oh!
There's skill panels?
New skills can be learned by spending- You can access- Oh!
Attack.
A good defense is a good attack.
That's what- That's right.
And then, boost health.
Unleashes a swinging kick with baton during that you will disappear and be- Oh wait, I should like that.
Actually, we'll get this too.
Oh, I can't.
It's alright, I'm committed.
Oh wait, I just don't have points.
Okay, nevermind.
Exactly.
The best defense is offense.
Did I finish it?
Oh, there's more skirmishes.
See current skills?
You can test weapons by using the virtual battlefield.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go to another skirmish.
Yeah, there's like a training room now too.
I'm really enjoying the new- I'm really enjoying this game actually.
It's actually- It's really fun.
It's like- It's such a- I will say I do miss like- I wish I could play like the other- The other general?
The other characters?
But like I understand they want to make this more of a story focused game.
But I do miss being able to play different kingdoms and stuff.
Oh, I got a long sword.
Wait, there's a different one?
Oh my god, he's also a fucking unit.
Oh shit.
Parried.
That's right, get parried.
This is definitely new.
Like a- This is like a new way that- A new way of- What's the word called?
A new way to tell the story.
Cause I don't think they've done it before like this.
Boop.
Yeah, they've never done it this way before to experience the story.
Yeah, they definitely changed it up.
Oh my god, wait, there's another one?
I didn't even- I was like, who are you?
I didn't even notice this guy.
Alright, don't worry, I'm trying out the new combo.
It's X and then- Oh shit, he did it- Okay, wait.
It's X- Please, let me use my combo!
It's not fair.
I'm trying to use my combo.
How would I ever learn?
Nice, parry.
I don't even know who you are.
That combo was too hard for Doki.
Cause I'm trying to learn my X combo!
I want like this so I can get this move.
I'm glad they made it similar to the old ones.
I didn't like the- How they did the- How they tried to change up the formula.
With like, the last Dynasty Warrior game formula was so- I didn't like that.
But for this one, I really liked the way they made it similar to the classic Dynasty Warriors.
But also a whole new thing.
Like their own- A different spin to it.
But I do miss being able to play.
The one thing I really miss is that in the older games, you could play each character.
And then like, each character has its own unique story to it.
And you follow their story.
And that's what I miss.
I used to love that.
I used to love the way they did it back then.
But like, it's interesting that now you're like, a third party experiencing the story.
So, I say we should call it a day.
My brother should be back any minute now.
My favorite was when they did a story per character.
I miss having a tiger as a pet.
I miss- I miss having a tiger.
Oh, and riding the elephant.
Yeah.
But we're poor!
This is exactly why we're always poor, Guan Yun!
It's not always about honor.
How would Zhang Fei buy his alcohol?
You were a great help to us.
I'm glad we met back there.
It was an honor.
I'm happy to have helped.
Oh my god, I'm gonna be the fourth sworn brother and they're not gonna write me out of history!
Now, everyone will know there were four brothers instead of three.
Right, guys?
The hidden fourth brother.
I missed a deadline.
Huh?
What?
Who are you, lady?
Yeah, who are you?
Zhuhua?
Oh my gosh, she's so pretty.
Oh no, she's Chunni!
I wish I could customize my character.
Could you be less cryptic, lady?
You didn't answer my question!
What?
She just ignored me!
You wish to stop him, do you not?
Unfortunately, yeah.
Unfortunately, yes.
The Yellow Turbans who rose up for peace have now become the...
Like, why give me a choice?
I feel like if I picked any, it wouldn't... She would say the same thing.
So, I have come with advice.
Oh, what's the advice?
The Yellow Turbans use magic from the heavens.
But their magic is nothing but an illusion.
Oh my god, the magic from the heavens.
They sometimes burn incense nearby to cause hallucinations.
I knew it!
I knew that boy didn't exist!
I knew he bought the wrong incense.
It is an ability that only you possess.
Only me?
Am I specialized?
I must go.
But we will meet again.
I knew it.
I fucking knew that the innkeeper bought the wrong incense.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anything...
Oh, I can sell now.
Wait, is there a new...
Recruit spear.
Boost strong attack.
Wait...
That's plus 20.
I like that.
Yes, equip please.
And then I can sell my old one.
This is the one I have so I can sell this.
And then I'll sell this.
Do I have any letters?
Any fan mail?
Oh shit!
Thank you, NotDoki.
Oh pardon my... Oh my god, I'm building my fan base!
I'm recruiting more dragons!
We were all certain that we were done for.
But then you gallantly appeared and put a stop to those villains.
Rumors speak of a mysterious warrior who rushed to the aid.
Could it be?
No, perhaps I ought not to pry.
In case, please allow us to thank you for what...
Thank you for the super chat, Village Chief!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I got a great bird's wing.
Okay, what did John Fae get me?
You were in your room, so I'm leaving... Oh my god, take these off my hands, will you?
You can use them to refine gems.
An old jeweler lives near my house.
And his age is catching up, so he's hanging up his precious tools for good.
If I knew worthy of inheriting them, I figured someone as handy as you would be able to get the most out of them.
They say that having that old man's gem attached to your weapon can bring good fortune and...
Did he, like...
Did he give me a diamond?
Whoa, John Fae, whoa!
Oh my god, whoa!
He super chats with gems!
Okay, gems.
Okay, let's see, what can I create?
There are five possible types of gems that can be created.
Okay.
Oh, I created a vortex gem.
A gem is a special...
Uh, my first... Guys, I got my first Akasupa!
Well equipped.
Thanks, John Fae, for the Akasupa!
It will grant special effects to any attacks you perform with a weapon.
Gems can only be obtained by using Pyroxen to create them.
Oh, cool.
But how do I equip it?
Okay, what's this?
It has been decreed that those who fight to bring order shall be provided with...
To aid their... Oh, I got another!
I got 30?!
John Fae gave me one?!
What the fuck?!
John Fae, you cheap bastard!
30?!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I might as well just max it out.
I got scammed!
Alright, nice.
Okay, battle.
How do I... Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Boost damage expands attack range by 12.
Boost damage dealt restores 30 health for every...
Activates a 32% chance to automatically block an attack.
I think I want to extend the attack.
I feel like that's really strong.
In general.
Is there anything else here?
No?
Wait, great bird's wing.
Boosts health by 10%.
Yeah, let's do that.
Alright.
Yeah, plus attack range sounds incredible.
Jesus Christ, I thought I was like, wow, John Fae!
He got me one gem, and then the fucking government gave me 30.
Like...
I was like, what the fuck?
You mean I could have had 30 gems all along?
Wait, what's this?
I found more rocks.
I was like, there's no way it was just...
Okay, what is the attack...
Oh my...
What is the attack range anyway?
Unlike...
Like, how far is the...
It's ranked.
That's fucking right.
Where's the other general?
Oh, there you are.
I see you.
You're 6 feet tall.
Oh, I'm so good at parrying.
Oh my god, I'm fucking gaming.
That's right, X and then X.
How am I supposed to use my X combo?
Nice.
I did it.
I love the victory music.
It's such a classic.
Attacking from another PC.
Am I gonna fight bugs?
Oh.
Oh, it's just random commentary.
What?
Why are they talking?
Oh, unlock.
I thought I was actually gonna start swatting some bugs.
I was literally getting excited.
I was like, oh my god, I'm gonna start swatting.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna start swatting.
Okay, let me...
I feel like I should get rid of these first.
People talk.
I'm the main character.
The only person that should be talking is me.
Okay, let's get rid of him.
Alright, nice.
That's right.
You won't even get to move.
Get out.
Alright.
Get away from me.
Move along.
I'm here to fight the mighty Wuhan General.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Oh shit, I missed a parry.
That's okay, he doesn't know that.
Okay, nice.
Please.
You are little guys, you don't...
Oh fuck, it's a...
It's a right attack.
You can't parry right attacks.
I didn't remember that.
Oh no.
Nice.
Here we go.
That's right.
Goodbye.
Ba-da-da-ba-da-dum!
Yay!
Ba-da-da-da-dum!
Alright, how many...
Oh, I still have zero skill points?
Okay, I should be able to...
cross the boat here.
And then head to the next city.
Alrighty.
Who cares?
Who cares about this child?
Oh, wow.
This is my story.
Who cares about what this child thinks?
Um...
Oh, it's like...
I wanna use the sphere.
I like the long range.
Honestly.
I think the long range is really nice.
There's like nothing...
Yeah, there's nothing here.
I don't think I have extra letters from people.
We'll grab this.
And then we'll steal somebody's money here.
And...
Oh, we're in Yan province now.
Wow.
Where do we go?
Is that Lu Bu?
Guys, do not pursue Lu Bu.
Guys, I heard...
Guys, this is a bad place.
We should never go in there.
Time to pursue Lu Bu, I guess.
Do it!
Challenge him!
Uh...
New province...
Where do I progress the story?
Is it this?
Oh, there it is.
Huh?
That's right.
God wants money!
The heavens demand your cash!
Alright, let's see how hot they are.
Hahaha!
Alright, it's time to judge.
Wait!
No way!
Is that...
Time for the...
What?
Is that his voice?
No!
Oh my god!
No way!
No fucking way!
Who is he?
No way!
No!
Okay, the third guy!
Oh my god, he's like...
He's somebody too.
He's somebody.
I'm trying to remember his name.
It's CapCap now.
Is that Xiaohu Yun?
I was like, there's no way!
I was like, why is he hot too?
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, for those who don't know what Xiaohu Yun looks like...
I was like...
Um...
No...
This is what he used...
Okay, this is...
This is what he's known to look like.
So I was like...
Why?
I'm not used to seeing him...
Fucking hot!
Because he was never supposed to be hot!
I was like, no way!
Xiaohu Yun looks like...
This is what he used to look like.
This is what Xiaohu Yun...
I was not ready...
To see him like this.
I was honestly...
It like, it threw me off.
It actually threw...
Like, Xiaohu Dun, I like...
Xiaohu Dun, I can see...
But Xiaohu Yun...
From dad...
To dad...
He had a glow up.
Oh my god.
They like...
What happened to dadness?
Do you worry?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so sad.
Oh yeah, Xiaohu Dun never got a haircut.
Sorry, Xiaohu Yun.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not...
Like...
Okay, CaoCao.
CaoCao also like...
It's...
CaoCao is also different too.
But like...
Yun surprised me the most.
Because...
If anybody was gonna look like a dad...
It was him.
He has always...
Looked like a dad.
For...
Like an old man.
For nine games.
And then suddenly I see that guy.
And I was like, oh my god.
That's...
Oh my god.
Just wait for XinXianDeV.
What happened to...
Do all the random NPCs just take my mustaches away?
The...
Only NPCs get to have mustaches.
I can't.
Why is Tao Tao...
Even with Tao Tao so blurry.
I can't.
He's so...
It's so weird.
It's...
I just...
I can't.
I just feel like he was born with a mustache at that point.
The mustache is just in DLC.
I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let this ragged band of volunteers show that we can be of service to the mighty Han Wait for him to hit Fury Oh my god, why is your hair not spiky?
For evil I like how like they always make Kao Kao's hair spiky just to be like he's the evil one You will serve under Cao Cao And fight together in the vanguard acceptable, of course Like I can Concluded don't let us down
My lord, you have returned.
He's so short!
Why is he so short?
Why is he shorter than Liu Bei?
They are volunteer force They will cross the other turbans in Nioh province They will be under my command in the coming battle He's so small Why is he shorter?
Allow me to officially introduce myself My name is Cao Cao I look forward to seeing you in the future 5 foot 1?
I didn't know he was 5 foot 1 Wait, he was?
Oh my god
Oh my god Still hot Always will be Never change When he gets one eye He gets even hotter guys He gets so cool when he has only one eye
Not even his final... Yeah, not even his final four.
Oh,
sorry.
I got distracted.
I got distracted in his eyes.
I don't know what you said.
I don't know what you said, but understood.
Please don't... Go back to him.
Oh, thank you.
Go back to him.
Oh my god, why is... Okay, Chow Chow doesn't even sound cool.
He used to sound so cool, but then Chow Ho Dun...
Oh, he never... He never changes.
He's always cool.
His voice actor is always like peak no matter what language.
My man has one too many eyes.
Not Doki.
Oh.
Okay.
Can't wait to see you without an eye.
Oh my god.
No, guys.
No, you don't understand.
When he gets that eyepatch... Oh my god.
If you thought he was cool now, the eyepatch raises him to another level.
You can't... Guys, everyone thought he was... You can't lie.
You can't... Even if you're not attracted to men, you cannot lie.
That he is fucking cool.
He was actually one of the best... He was the best...
One of the best character designs in Dynasty Warriors.
Everyone loves to play him.
Everyone loves to be him.
I'm ready.
Battle of... Okay, I'm...
I can lie easily.
It's time.
I'm ready.
Everyone wanted to be him.
Me too.
I miss his long hair too.
His long hair was so cool.
Was?
Still is.
I'm not attracted to men.
But to Xiaohudun?
On an unrelated note, can't wait for you to play Metal Gear Solid Delta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, General of Earth Zhang Bao is one of the younger brothers of Zhang Xiao, leader of the Yellow Turbans.
In this battle, we eliminate the Yellow Turbans' leadership, which will in turn stifle their resistance.
We will be leading the government forces.
That losing both of them will result in defeat.
Be careful.
Caca will hardly consider a victory if we lost a commander in process.
Xiaohudun, but with Yuan by my side, I have nothing to fear from the Yellow Turbans.
You're safe with us, my lord.
We'll guard you with our lives.
I need to know what... I want to know what Wu looks like.
I need to know what they look like.
What does Sun Tze look like?
You must not let our guard down any time during this battle.
The meeting is finished.
Make sure you're thoroughly prepared.
I need to know.
No one messaged you yet.
Can we change the battle?
Do you wish to proceed?
The game will pause whenever... the game will pause only also when messages... the game will not pause.
I don't think we need to pause when messages are shown.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, battle areas with active fighting are shown in blue if allies are winning.
Or Sun Tze En.
Sun Tze En, right?
I want to know what Sun Tze En looks like.
I keep forgetting that Sun Tze En fucking dies so fast.
Because the story became like...
Alright, there we go.
Come on, let's get them out of here.
They're so easy.
That's right, parry!
Oh shit, I forgot to do the other parry.
Alright, get out of here!
He's already dead.
What did he say?
Guess we'll never know!
Spoiled!
Okay, we gotta take this hapless.
Get through!
Let me in!
Alright, let's get rid of all these men.
Yeah, Wu's storyline is like...
I remember in the very first few games of Dynasty Warriors, they made it seem like Sun Tze En was very, very important to the Three Kingdoms, but he literally...
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Oh my... Wu!
Witchcraft!
I thought he was like, super important.
And then like, later on in the newer games, they're like...
By the way, he dies like, after the first chapter.
Oh shit.
What do I see?
Survey with your eyes of the sacred bird?
LT.
What do I see with my special eyes?
What?
Moved in search of superstitious...
Oh, it's a vase!
My brain!
You are a guardian of peace.
Use this power to do what must be done.
You possess a special power called the Eyes of the Sacred Bird, allowing you to see things.
This includes the ability to perceive the flow of incense.
Your eyes show the health of those as well as the situation.
Use them well to maintain an advantage.
What the fuck?
Oh, I can see their HP on the other side!
Where is the incense?
Oh, it's up here.
Alright, I'm breaking the jar.
That's right!
No more sorcery!
We can't get high anymore.
That's fucking right.
Reveal yourself!
And it was nothing!
Oh my god.
Oh, and it was nothing!
Where is he?
Where is the six foot man?
That's right!
You may be tall, but can you handle this?
That's fucking right.
No sor- what did I- where am I?
Like, I'm part of the trees now.
Nice, we did it.
The sorcery has stopped the advance of...
Alright,
let's go this way.
We gotta get rid of this base.
Oh no.
Oh, I broke it just in time.
Don't worry, I'm gonna do this combo I learned.
It's X, and then X, and then X, and then X, and then- Okay, hey, hey, hey, hey man.
I was supposed to do my X move, guys.
That's so rude.
I can never do my X combo.
Like, I don't understand.
Why gave me that combo if I can't even do it?
It just gets interrupted.
What a difficult combo.
Alright.
I just- oh shit.
Where is- Okay, this is where- It's like Dicky Assassin's Creed.
It's like- It's like picking the eagle screech.
Alright, smash.
Wait, there's another one?
Okay.
Where's the other one?
Oh shit.
Where the- oh, it's on the other side.
Oh fuck, come on!
Wah!
I can't!
The sound!
Freedom!
I'm sorry.
I like- I enjoy the little things.
I enjoy the little things in life.
Freedom!
Woo!
We did it!
Alright, get him!
Get him!
He's trying to use witchcraft!
Alright, X and then- oh my god, I did it!
Guys!
I did- guys!
I just did the combo!
Oh my go- I just- guys, I just did the X combo.
Are you proud of me?
The hardest combo I've ever done.
I did it.
Yay!
I saved Kow Kows!
Oh shit, um.
Whoops.
Um, sorry.
I saw a door and I just- I tried to move so it- It came around the ear.
I couldn't help it.
I was like, you- you fuck this door.
That's right, interruption.
You had to hit that door.
I thought- guys, sorry.
I thought I was playing Dynasty Warriors 6.
Nice.
Alright.
Did I get rid of the base?
This is my base now.
This is my house.
Wait.
Oh shit!
Chao Chao!
Oh fuck!
I'm coming over!
Oh my god, you're still a baby!
I'm coming over, Chao Chao!
You're still- I forgot you're still a baby!
You haven't grown your must- Chao Chao!
You haven't grown back!
God, Chao- what the- what happened to you?
I'm sorry.
I didn't- I didn't realize you were still a baby!
I'm coming!
Don't worry!
I didn't realize!
I went too fast.
Guys, he was still a baby and I didn't realize.
Oh my god.
It's a little scary though.
I'm here!
Don't worry!
Don't let him hit you!
Nice.
Alright.
How could you let a guy with a fan fucking beat you up like that?
Honestly, so embarrassing.
So fucking embarrassing.
I swear if like, he dies to arrows, I swear to god.
Like, I- come on.
Oh my god, he's so tanky!
It's cause he's so fucking big!
Like, he's like 7 foot tall!
What am I supposed to do when they're 7 feet tall?
Like, Chao Chao is just 5 feet!
Like, he was not- he was not meant to be in fights like this.
You-
Alright.
Is he okay?
Oh shit, Chao Chao!
Chao Chao, don't worry!
I got you!
I- I got you, don't worry!
You're safe!
Okay, now I can help the people on this side.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Cho Jin!
I'm so sorry!
I had to help Chao Chao!
Oh no.
This is so bad.
Give me a sec, I gotta- it's over here.
It's over here.
Don't worry, I'm just gonna run past them.
I like how he's like, I shall guard the base with my life!
I shall guard this base with my life!
Guys, I don't think he guarded the base, guys.
I- I- I don't think he did it.
Worst soldier ever.
Alright, I gotta get rid of these guys.
Like, I cannot be bothered.
Don't worry, Gwon Yoon.
What, Chao Hu?
I can- Guys, there's only one of me, guys.
I think- Oh no.
Oh, come on!
Please!
Hit all my- Chao Hu, no!
Oh my god, I cannot kill everything!
Please!
Stop making me do everything!
Chao Hu, don't!
No!
Guys, this is looking bad.
I think I'm gonna get my first loss, guys.
This is actually looking bad.
I- But it's not even- Oh my god, Chao Chao, please!
Chao Chao, I have to kill him!
Chao Chao, please!
I have to kill him first!
Okay, I'm coming over!
Chao Chao, fucking live!
I'm fucking running over!
Chao Chao, please!
I'm climbing the- Live!
Live!
Oh my god!
Guys, this is my first loss!
Guys, I don't think- Holy shit!
Guys, this is not looking so-
Okay, I'm coming over!
I'm coming!
Please!
I'm fucking- I went too fast!
I- I- I went too fast, guys.
I think- Oh my god!
Oh no!
Guys, I went too fast!
I'm coming over!
Please!
Chao Chao!
Oh my god, Chao Chao!
Oh, thank god, he ate a bun!
Oh, thank god!
Oh my god!
He ate bread!
Oh, thank god!
Oh, I'm so happy!
He ate bread!
There's still hope!
There's actually still hope!
Oh my god!
I'm- I'm gonna- I'm actually- I'm gonna head over to him.
I can't- I don't trust Chao Chao!
You have to live!
You-
Like, I can't!
Oh my god, just keep eating bread!
Actually, just- just keep eating bread!
Please!
Please, that's all I ask!
Like, I don't ask for much!
Just keep eating!
Oh god!
That's all I want!
Just keep eating!
Legitimately, just keep eating bread, Chao Chao!
That's all you need to do!
You have no other!
You have no other mission!
You just eat bread!
Oh my god, he's so strong though!
Like, he's so strong!
He's so strong!
Oh my god, okay!
Come on!
Oh!
Nice!
He's the last- Oh, thank god!
Eat!
Oh my god!
I saved him!
No defeat here!
Brent saves lives!
Oh, thank fucking god!
It was so scary!
The Brent for the win!
Alright, L-B-Y.
L-Y.
Enable the use of L-B-Y.
Alright, that was so stressful, not gonna lie.
That was actually so fucking loud!
I think I killed people too fast that my little guys just kept going for it.
I don't think they were ready for it.
I need 20 points.
I have 13.
Liv!
I literally soloed the war.
Wait, you're right!
Why am I not invited to the war?
I fucking saved his life!
Oh!
That's right.
They fucking ran!
I was there for you, Tau Tau!
They all ran!
Why, thank you.
Lord Tau Tau.
We owe our success in battle to this warrior.
That's me!
That's me, guys!
I look like such an emo kid too.
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
He's gonna take an arrow to the eye soon.
It's gonna look so fucking cool.
It's gonna look so cool.
And you're like, thank god he lost his eye.
Because it was so hot.
Wait, why is it- Oh my god, guys, do you see this child?
Oh my god.
Guys, guys, do you guys also see this child, guys?
I'm just looking at the child and being like, what the fuck?
Yes, I like it too.
I like how Shao Dun is just posing like a model.
He's just like, god, I don't know what's going on, but I look so cool.
It was like, arms on his hips too.
He's farming aura.
Oh my god, the more I fight, the more I remember.
That's what you want.
Who?
But who didn't survive?
Wait, we have the same outfit.
Same clothes.
I'm loving this game right now.
Oh wait.
I think this ability is my favorite.
I love this ability.
I can't, I'm sorry, this is actually my favorite ability.
Okay, okay, sorry, I'll talk to you again.
Hey there, that's you, isn't it?
I bet you can do it.
Oh,
okay.
Wait, do I have... oh, it's just my tent.
What's this?
Suppression of you province?
Do I, should I rest?
No, I don't feel like it.
I know, it's like relationship.
I was like, what is that supposed to mean?
What's this camp?
Is this a mission?
The Jinn province.
Are we romancing the three kingdoms now?
Yeah,
this game is really good.
I'm like, I'm really enjoying it right now.
Ah, finally, the romance of the romance of the three kingdoms.
I've been waiting for this my entire life.
That's me.
Oh my god, he's like, he said my name.
I'm so happy.
Sun Jian!
Okay.
What does he look like?
Oh my god, finally.
Oh my...
No!
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Okay, with the suit.
Oh, is he the only old man?
Oh my god.
He looks... yeah, that definitely looks like a guy that's about to die.
He has... yeah, that looks like a man that's about to fucking die.
The last old man.
He's only thirty... oh my... he has earrings now!
Oh my god, he looks like a fucking pirate.
Yeah.
In the older games, they made the leaders all the same age.
Oh my god.
The last old man in this game.
And he only lives for like one to two fights.
Oh my god, I like the earrings feature.
Cause like, um...
His kingdom is more focused on like pirates and water.
So I really like the design elements that they added.
Where like, yeah, they're like known to be really great at naval battles.
So I like that for this one, they made him more like a pirate... like a pirate.
They put... to distinguish between the kingdoms.
And fire too, yeah, fire.
That's why they're red.
What's this one?
The Suppression of Yu Province.
Okay, wait.
Let me get some upgrades first.
I'm gonna get some upgrades first.
Where's my tent?
I wanna see my fan mail.
Alright, I don't have any new fan mail?
Where's my fan mail, guys?
Alright, nice.
I'll grab upgrade these.
Um...
No!
No fan mail!
No more mail.
Alright.
Aw, I really don't wanna stop playing.
I'm actually really enjoying this game.
But tomorrow's gonna be a super long stream.
And I wanna make sure I don't overdo it, guys.
Ah!
I'm actually... I'm actually enjoying this game a lot right now.
Like, um...
Oh my god.
No super chats, guys.
No.
Guys, I can't believe it.
I don't have any new super chats from Ancient China.
I'm so sad from the very first Dragoons.
But I'm loving this playthrough a lot.
And also, Black5, thank you 5, get the chips.
Thank you, thank you.
And we're definitely gonna do a part 2.
Um, we're definitely gonna do a part 2, um, next week.
Uh, but, uh...
Honestly, I highly, highly recommend buying this game.
Cause, like, I've never been so hyped over a new...
It's been so long.
It's been so long since the last Dynasty Warriors game.
And honestly, I am really hooked on this one.
This one is... it's so good.
I think they really, really went beyond, uh, beyond for this one.
Like, I'm... yeah, it's... oh my god.
Um, the story... I think, like, the voice acting and the story and, like, how they did the combat.
And, uh, and just everything about it so far, I'm enjoying it a lot.
And, like, seeing all the characters be re... like, all the new redesigns.
It's funny and also, like, I like some of the new character redesigns.
But it's also funny to see them so young.
Like, I'm pretty sure they're gonna age them up.
There's no way.
They're not gonna give Tao Tao his fucking mustache.
So I'm pretty sure they're gonna, like, age them up as we go.
And I'm, like, I'm super excited.
I'm really, really excited to see what they look like the longer you play.
Um, um, and, uh, and yeah, I'm enjoying... I'm definitely...
Yeah, being so... it did.
It gave me whiplash.
I was like, oh my god.
I was like, I was like, where's your mustache?
Where did it... oh my god.
Where did it go?
Um, but, um, but yeah, it's been really fun so far.
And I really, really highly recommend you guys to check out the game if you... and play it yourself.
And, uh, I love it.
I love it so much.
I really do love it so far.
Uh, we're gonna play... play Duel Part 2.
I won't finish this game.
I actually legitimately, uh...
I legitimately really want to finish this game because I... I like it a lot.
And I would... I would have played this a lot longer if I didn't have a livestream tomorrow.
Um...
If I didn't have a livestream tomorrow, I would have... I would have kept... I would have kept playing.
Uh...
Um...
SRO, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Doki, please play more.
Yes, I will, definitely.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the superchat.
Doki, it's me, Anton, from China.
Everything is on fire, but I still think the dynasty can be saved.
Definitely.
Thank you for the superchat, Anton.
Thank you.
Thank you from Han, China.
Marcello, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not Doki, thanks for saving my village from the tyranny of the Yellow Turbans.
Here is a meager offering I got from the still-warm bodies of my family.
Thank you for the superchat, Marcello.
Thank you, thank you.
I knew I still had some superchats from ancient China.
I knew it.
Nexy, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dear Not Doki, I think you're neat.
From your biggest fan.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
It's been a really fun game.
Arsateria, thank you for your third superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nothing bad with Cookie Kratos again, Doki.
We're gonna finish God of War tomorrow!
We're gonna finish it, I believe in us.
We're also gonna have a special announcement at the beginning of the stream for God of War.
So please tune in to that stream if you wanna know what the special announcement is.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna rest my voice.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!